Devil Facial Tumour Disease is a very strange and bizarre new type of cancer
It usually starts off
as a small tumour, a little nodule, on the
lips or inside the mouth, or somewhere on the face
however, this rapidly, within the course of a few weeks to months, develops into a massive ulcerating tumour.
As the tumours grow especially when
they're inside the oral cavity, inside the mouth
the tumours can remove dentition,
can displace bones from the jaw so it is
very hard for the animal to feed
and it's hard to compete for food as
being scavengers with other Tasmanian devils.
But also because it's a cancer, it is
creating a lot of damage in the internal organs.
So I think there is a combination of factors
that makes that animal die within the year.